and breaking first at five henderson
police on the scene of what they're
calling an armed robbery it is right
near green valley parkway and paseo
verde parkway good evening to you thank
you for joining us at five i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise feltes we want to
get right out to victoria saha she just
arrived at the scene victoria just
arrived
hey denise and brian we're still
gathering details here but you can see
here at fountain hills it is a gated
community henderson police is blocking
the road we a few minutes ago we just
saw several police cars
rush into this community and then there
was an ambulance here on standby they
also just about a minute or two ago went
in there we were told that some
residents near a house there were told
to evacuate what we are learning right
now is henderson police say there was an
armed robbery nearby but residents tell
us that they are hearing that that
suspect might be inside again this is a
very active scene residents are not
allowed to go i'll have my photographer
point over there traffic is being
diverted
residents here are standing outside
wondering what is happening they don't
have too many details but we're trying
to gather everything right now for you
guys again stay with us brian and denise
back to you